(chiming music)
- Whenever you email Canvas @ Yale,
it's usually the one of the two of us,
so we do have faces.
This is what we look like.
We're always smiling when
we hear the complaints,
so it's great.
(audience chuckling)
We're actually talking about
the upcoming external apps in Canvas,
and one of the things we
did want to talk about
is what exactly is an external app.
So an external app is a
third-party application
that can be embedded and integrated
within Canvas seamlessly.
We actually heard about one, Piazza,
is actually a third-party app,
so a lot of the tools that
you use, the sign-up tool
and a couple the other ones
that we were listening to,
are considered third-party apps.
They actually are really
great for if you want to
have a something in your class
that Canvas doesn't quite do,
there's an app for that, so it's great.
We also want to talk about the process
of requesting external apps.
There's a lot of technology out there
that can help your teaching
and we know that it can be
almost overwhelming to look at
all the technology available to you.
So there is an external app request form
that you can fill out saying, hey,
I heard about this technology.
I think will be beneficial,
can we integrate it?
That is step one.
And we do have deadlines, so fall,
you would have to request the
external app by March 1st,
spring is October 1st, and
summer is December 1st.
Once the request for the
external app is created,
we then at the Center for
Teaching and Learning,
we get a demo of the app.
After the demo, we say, hey,
this is really great tool.
I think it could benefit
a lot of people at Yale.
It goes through a wonderful process
where it's the OGC Registrar, ITS vetting.
This step in the process
can take between weeks and
months of the process time,
so that's why we have the
deadline so far in advance
because it has to be ensured
that we're protecting
the student data and
the student information,
because that's very
important to us as whole,
and to us who use that technology.
Once it goes through that lovely process,
it actually then gets the
approval for the integration,
and then it gets integrated.
The Canvas team will then
integrate it into the courses.
We then have a pilot,
which can run about one to two semesters
depending on the pilot.
It could be one course, it
could be an entire department,
or it could be university-wide.
And then we also have
a post-pilot analysis,
so that's what worked, what didn't work,
was this tool successful?
This is the, essentially,
the entire process:
the external apps.
It's really fun.
(audience laughing)
Especially that vetting part.
So the non-integrated external app use,
so say, for example, you found a tool
that you want to use in your class,
but you don't really want to
incorporate it or integrate it
in Canvas, you just want
to try it out first.
Well, with that in mind, we
do want to be very cognizant
of what student data is
going to be out there,
so we are going to be working,
you can come to us, and say,
hey, I want to use this
app, can you please
help me make sure that
my students information's
not gonna be sold by Facebook
or anything like that?
So you can actually work with us to ensure
that the data is gonna be protected
and what student information
is gonna be passed,
so that's the fun part,
and you can always email Canvas@Yale.edu
for any questions about this.
We have been learning a
lot about this process,
and a lot of tools that you guys
have been wanting to integrate.
So a lot of the tools,
before we talk about the upcoming ones,
I do want to give an example
that say, for example,
Piazza was a tool that a
lot of faculty were using
but was not incorporated within Canvas.
We went through this whole process
and that's how it's now
a streamless integration.
So here's Kristi.
- Thank you, am I on?
Yeah, all right, so with
that, on the Piazza note,
I will jump to one of
the last bullet points
in my first slide, which
is Poll Everywhere,
which is going to be
integrated into Canvas.
So I'll start by saying that
just since we're on that topic.
So one of the other ones is VoiceThread.
A lot of the language courses
have already been using it,
and that's why we decided
to pilot it and see
if it's something that we should integrate
if so many people are already using it.
VoiceThread is basically their catch line:
Transforming media into
collaborative spaces
with video, voice, and text commenting.
I'll go over what this looks like.
And then PlayPosit is a new one.
We had the need to do
quiz types in videos,
so interactive quiz in videos essentially.
And then Poll Everywhere,
so many of you may have
already been using it,
but now with the help of Brian's team,
we're integrating it into Canvas.
I will start with VoiceThread.
It's a web-based platform that
enables teachers and students
to upload video, documents,
voice commenting,
and basically you can think of it
as a highly-interactive discussion space.
So we first started thinking about it
because we had complaints
about the discussion tool.
People wanted to be
able to do more with it,
so that's when we started
looking into VoiceThread,
so the look and feels like a slideshow.
I'll give you examples.
What's neat is that after media is added,
so let's say Jen added
some media to a slides,
me, as a teacher or a student,
could go in and comment
on any of that content that she put in.
And what's nice is that the integration
with all of these that
we just will mention
is that you can use it
like in assignments,
and it just goes right into the Gradebook.
So what does this look like,
and I'm just going to
do three quick slides
for the sake of time,
and overarching, click the
Create button, Add Media,
so, in this case, I think
I added an image file.
So I have these different things
I can choose to pick from,
what I want to add, and
I just grabbed a photo
from my computer, and
the first photo came up.
Yeah, this screenshot that
I took but I put this here
because you can add a couple
of different media types
so maybe I wanted to start with an image
and then go into a video
and then end with of some voice comment.
So to show you what it looks like
if I put it as an assignment,
I call this how to make a
comment that was the assignment,
and Jenn, luckily, your
picture's small enough,
I didn't want you to kill
me but I put you up there.
You can see that Tonia Tester,
which is Jenn’s account,
made a comment at this
point in this image,
and she also, along with me
watching her make that comment
in the VoiceThread, circled the dog's face
and she was talking about it.
So that's briefly what that looks like.
The next one is PlayPosit,
and I found this
on their Twitter: Play
videos posit questions,
so I guess that's why they named it that.
And again, this is like the
interactive quizzing feature,
so I will jump to that.
What's nice is that, let's say,
that I upload a three-minute film clip.
I can pause it at any time,
so maybe the first minute,
and say reflect on the
first minute of that video,
and they could submit
a discussion question
or some sort of comment.
These are the different types of things.
They can add multiple
choice for your response,
a couple of others, I'm
gonna go past it here
'cause I have an image of it.
And again the integration allows you to
align this with the Gradebook in Canvas.
What does this look like?
All right, so let's pretend
I went past the Canvas stuff,
I'm right in PlayPosit.
First thing, upload
your content from where?
So this is truly video.
Let's say that I had it in Vimeo,
I just paste the link there up at the top,
and the next thing I
see is the actual video.
So whenever I click on this these dots,
I get all of these options on
what do I want to add right there,
so maybe I made a syllabus video,
and in it, I was like
why did I just say that,
and then you know as a joke,
and so if people aren't paying attention,
you know, it really catches them.
and you can't go past the
video until you answer
the certain questions or click on a URL
or there's reflective pauses,
but these are the
different kinds of things
you can add to that.
And yep, just a little bit bigger
in case you couldn't see that.
What does this look like in a video?
What does a question look like?
I was just saying something, and I said,
in this video the presenter
will show you how to,
it says, fill in the blank
so they could write in their answer
and click Continue
and then right away you can choose
so that it gives them immediate feedback.
In this case, I got the question wrong
but I am able to see the correct answer,
and then I can continue on.
Yep, there's just another picture of it.
So already available in
Canvas in case you're curious.
We have this available on
our Help.Canvas.Yale.edu,
and you probably, a lot
of you already use Ares.
Its course reserves, you
may not even know it.
FacultyEnlight connects
you to the bookstore.
MobLab, SOM was using for gaming.
Piazza we heard about.
Perusall, Perusall allows
you to do annotation.
And then Panopto is our
media library software,
so I'll just click on
that link just because.
And here's our external apps overview
for the entire list of
everything we're doing,
so you can see what we're piloting,
what's already been approved,
what's been requested.
So yeah, questions?
- [Audience] Looking
back, (faint speaking),
you can just do it from YouTube?
I saw the button there on the PlayPosit.
Embed, you can just embed from YouTube?
- So the question was to embed
from YouTube into PlayPosit,
can you just paste the link?
The answer is yes.
- Yep.
- I'm a little hesitant to ask, but,
so you were talking a little bit about
external apps versus internal apps,
am I correct in saying that?
- [Jenn] It would be
integrated external apps
and then non-integrated external apps.
- I actually have a very
specific question about Panopto,
we integrate a lot of our
videos into our curriculum.
- Okay, Panopto, okay.
- Through Panopto,
but we can't just have them
download Canvas, correct?
They have to have Panopto.
Let's say they have an
iPod or an iPad or a phone,
they have to have both
apps downloaded, correct?
- Brian?
- They should play back in
a browser is that, sorry,
is that what the question?
Yeah, I guess I guess I just--
- They don't need to go to
another, the Panopto app.
- It doesn't have to be on their device.
- No.
- Okay.
All right, yeah, that's fine.
- If you've ever been on
a consultation with me
as soon as videos comes
up, I go, Brian, help me.
Does anybody have any other questions?
Oh, here you go.
- With the Poll Everywhere
app that's coming or yeah app.
I know right now you
can use like our phones
and anything web-enabled
in order to poll in
is that still gonna be a possibility?
Or do they have to get a library device?
- Oh, John has it, okay.
- Poll Everywhere will
actually be exclusively
either browser-based or an
app on a phone or a tablet,
so there won't be a physical
device that they'll check out.
- [Audience] In regards to the video,
are you guys gonna have any
plugins for closed captioning
and things that are gonna take place?
- [Kristi] Brian, again. (laughing)
Call me if I'm wrong,
but I believe that Canvas uses Amara,
and Panopto, you can add them
in and Panopto, Panopto-land.
What?
- [Brian] So through
the editor in Panopto,
you can add captions, actually all videos,
there's an automatic captioning procedure,
which is not accurate,
you would still need to
go back and correct them
but you're able to import those
and then correct them if you'd like.
John might have more to say about that.
- And the excellent help
article that Brian put together,
it's on the help pages that you can find
in the Canvas help pages section.
- Brian should have been a third person
for this presentation.
- [Audience] But leave
them microphone with Brian
'cause that, you know...
(laughing)
It might be straightforward
but I just don't,
I'm not sure I understand.
What would be the benefits
of using Poll Everywhere
through Canvas versus how we do it now,
which is either as part of
a PowerPoint or just online?
- Poll Everywhere, I mean,
it's gonna function somewhat similarly
When you integrate into the Canvas,
you can upload responses to Gradebook,
you can still do it through PowerPoint.
It just, we're piloting it to see if it's,
be a better, smoother
application than TurningPoint,
which is what we currently support.
So it might just be a
little easier to use,
It has the benefit, sorry, of also being
everything stored in the cloud,
so you don't have to
have your presentation
or carry all that information with you
or making sure you're uploading
the grades back to Canvas,
it can do all that automatically.
- Any more questions for Brian?
(audience laughing)
Awesome, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Well, thank you so much.
We really appreciate your
coming to the Lightning Talks
and again thank you to everyone
who helped make today happen
and if you have any feedback,
if you have any questions at all,
please feel free to reach
us at Canvas@Yale.edu,
and one of our team will get back to you,
and we look forward to
doing this again next year,
so we've, if you think
about it and find something,
we totally want you to present next year
so next year we hope you'll come back.
Oh, yes, and there are
remaining refreshments
and cookies and things.
Please help yourself.
Thank you.
(rhythmic dinging)